(bright music)
- [Zoe] In Southern Texas,
just a few miles from the Mexico border,
and almost three hours from San Antonio,
sits the quiet town of Del Rio.
Texas is a place where local politics
are often steeped in anti-LGBT rhetoric.
But in a wave of change,
Del Rio elected its first
openly gay mayor in 2018.
I'm Zoe Saldana from BESE,
and I'm teaming up with Great Big Story
to shine a light on
American Latinx excellence
around the country.
(lighthearted music)
- I'm Bruno Lozano, and I'm
the mayor of Del Rio, Texas.
I was born and raised
here in Del Rio, Texas.
I joined the military when I was 21.
I served in the Air Force
under Don't Ask, Don't Tell.
I left and lived in big cities,
and I came back to Del Rio, Texas in 2016.
(poignant music)
I was not openly gay until
maybe I was 15 years old.
Growing up, I was bullied,
because I was flamboyant.
I was feminine; I was more effeminate.
And being feminine is
considered a weakness
in the machismo culture that
permeates this entire area.
But the same people who bullied
me voted me into office.
- [Zoe] Bruno ran on a platform
built on infrastructure,
employment and tourism.
Despite running against an incumbent,
Bruno won his election
with 62% of the vote.
- I decided to run for office
because I've always believed in Del Rio
and its full potential.
On my campaign trail, I did
not run as a gay politician
or as a gay mayor.
I ran as Bruno, who happens to
be all of these other things.
Miss Carpenter, you may now have the floor
to speak for three minutes.
You can win people's hearts over
as long as you are true to yourself
and true to your mind and goal.
(gavel bangs)
(poignant music)
- [Zoe] Since becoming mayor,
Bruno has written support
resolutions for local initiatives,
appointed members to the Parks Committee
and Housing Authority,
but most importantly,
he has created a space
for people like him.
- [Bruno] For me, the future
of Del Rio is being a place
where people are welcome, are
inviting, and are different.
I left looking for acceptance
and looking for people like me,
but I chose to come back to Del Rio
because my community is here,
and it's important for
people who are different,
like myself, to be visible.
You can be gay, you can be different,
and you can still run for
office here in Del Rio, Texas,
and win an election.
(bright tones)